we have new information this morning
about former presidential aide Rob
Porter and when the White House knew
about accusations he abused his two
ex-wives the staff secretary resigned on
Wednesday CBS News confirms that last
January Porter told White House Counsel
Don McGann that a background check might
find problems in June the FBI sent a
file to the White House including claims
by the ex-wives that Porter abused them
it is unclear who reviewed that
information and in September Porter told
the White House the FBI had interviewed
him a second time then in November a
former girlfriend called McGann and told
him about the ex wives allegations at
that time again shared the information
about Porter with chief of staff John
Kelly
a month later kelly approved giving
Porter an expanded role in the White
House there are so many questions here a
timeline to follow the White House has a
lot of questions to answer and Bravo to
the women for speaking up it gives you a
whole different perspective yeah what's
going on there were police reports were
pictures lots of allegation
documentation and this is about the
chief of staff who was brought in to
bring order to the situation and so now
this is a test of his order inside the
White House and Rob Porter even though
the role says staff secretary he has a
very important job I don't think that we
should overlook that either one of the
most important jobs is White House